ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS
BAIT WELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABRERA CHANG DALLY DODD THERE
ARE SO LG ANI GLAZER GONZALES
ROSE HERTZBERG HELLO WAY SO-
TADO. JACKSON JONES LLEVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MINING WARLOCK
AROUND HE'LL SEND HAN PORTS AND
TINO ROCK RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG WHY CASKEY WINNER WELK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BUYER
CHAPLAIN SYSTEM SHOW CORPSMAN
AFTER WHICH WILL BE LED AND
LEADS BY SENATOR DODD. LET US
BE MINDFUL OF GOD'S PRESENCE.
OUR PRAYER TODAY'S A POETIC
VERSION OF THE BEATITUDES BY
STEVE GARNETS HOMES. BLESSED
ARE YOU WHO ARE EMPTY HANDED
YOU ARE IN GOD'S HANDS. BLESSED
ARE YOU WHO ARE BROKEN HEARTED.
YOUR BROKEN HEART IS GOD'S.
BLESSED ARE YOU WHO ARE
POWERLESS LAUGHS POWER WILL
NEVER FAIL YOU. BLESSED ARE YOU
WHO WISH SHE WERE CLOSER TO GOD.
YOU'RE WISHING IS GOD IN YOU.
BLESSED ARE YOU WHO ARE KIND
THE UNIVERSE WILL BE KIND TO
YOUR SOUL. BLESSED ARE YOU WHO
SEEK ONE NOUS YOU ARE ONE.
BLESSED ARE YOU WHO STANDS WITH
THE POOR THAT IS WHERE GOD IS
STANDING. AND BLESSED ARE YOU
WHO ARE WOUNDED WHEN YOU STANDS
FOR JUSTICE. YOU ARE EMBRACED
YOU ARE IN FOLDERS YOU STAND
AMONG THE GREAT A MAN. MEMBERS
A GUEST PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
MEREKA OBSERVER APARTMENT. AND
ONE SESSION AND IT IS A WITH.
ALL. YEAH. FOR MEMBERSHIP
PUBLISHED PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR THERE ARE NINE. MESSAGE
FROM THE GOVERNOR WE'LL BE
DOING READ. MESSAGE FROM THIS
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DOING READ
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES WILL BE
DOING READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS RUG
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THANK
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH THROUGH JANUARY THIRTY
OF TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. INTRODUCTION TO
FIRST READING OF BILLS WILL BE
DEAN READ BUILDER DEAN READ.
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILES
SICKENS. SECOND READING. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FORTY.
SENATE THIRD READING.
THE FIRST
ITEM UP IS A FILE ITEM SEVEN S.
C. R. SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO
PRISONER COMPENSATION SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AS YOUR SIXTY NINE
EXPRESSES THE LEGISLATORS
SUPPORT FOR FAIR AND JUST WAGES
FOR INCARCERATED PERSONS AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY NEED TO
EXAMINE. THEIR PAY SCALE TODAY
IN CALIFORNIA FORTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE IMPRISONED
WHO WORK FULL TIME EARNING
BETWEEN EIGHT SENT TO AT MOST A
DOLLAR AN HOUR WITH IN OUR
PRISON SYSTEM THOUSANDS OF
INCARCERATED LABOR'S WORK AS
WHAT TRADITIONS. CARPENTERS
COOKSORDERLIES PEARL'S BROUGHT
A BRAILLE TRANSCRIBERS SOAK
SCREEN PRINTERS AND MANY OTHER
INTERPOSITION AND SISTER IN
SUCH A TO OPERATION OF OUR
STATE INSTITUTIONS ANOTHER
SEVEN THOUSAND INCARCERATED
WORKERS ARE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRISON. INDUSTRY AUTHORITY
WHICH MANUFACTURES AND SELLS
PRODUCTS MADE BY INCARCERATED
WORKERS TO OUR VERY OWN STATE
DEPARTMENTS. CAL PIA GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE BECAUSE THE
STATE PAYS MARKET RATE FOR
THESE ITEMS AND THE WORKERS
ASSEMBLE A MANUFACTURE THESE
PRODUCTS EARNED ONLY A FRACTION
OF THE MARKET WAGE INCARCERATED
WORKERS PRODUCED OVER. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED GOODS AND SERVICESINCLUDED ROAD SIGNS CLOTHING
CLEANING PRODUCTS LIKE SOME
PLATES FOR FURNITURE. WHICH HI
THIS BUILDING AS WELL
ADDITIONAL OF THE FORTY TWO
THOUSAND IN CARTS FOR WORKERS
CAL OVER THREE THOUSAND CARS TO
PEOPLE WORK AS CONSERVATION
GROUP MEMBERS RISKING THEIR
LIVES PROTECTING PEOPLE AND
PROPERTY FROM FIRE WATER
EARNING A DOLLAR AN HOUR. FOR
SOMEONE MAKING A DOLLAR HOUR
TOTAL MONTHLY EARNINGS WORKING
FORTY HOURS A WEEK WOULD BE A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DOLLARS.
AFTER THE MANDATORY RESTITUTION
TO DEDUCTIONS MONTHLY EARNINGS
WILL DROP DOWN TO SEVENTY TWO
DOLLARS NOT ONLY ARE THESE
BRAVE MEN AND OMEN PAID ONE
TWENTY SEVENTH OF THE EARNINGS
SWORN FOR FIREFIGHTERS BUT THEY
ARE FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE. OBJECT REPEATED
INJURIES AND EIGHT TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SMOKE
INHALATION RELATED INJURIES
ULTIMATELY PAIN INCARCERATED
WORKERS ARE FAIR AND JUST WAIT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO OBTAIN AN
EQUITABLE SHARE. OF THE WORK
THEY ARE PERFORMING AND A
BETTER AND BETTER PREPARE
THEMSELVES FOR THE COMMUNITY
ONCE THEY REENTER. WITH
INCREASED WAGES IN CARS OR
WORKERS CONTRIBUTE MONETARY
MEANS TO THEIR FAMILIES PAY
CHILD SUPPORT DRASTICALLY
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
PAID TOWARDS THE RESTITUTION
FEES ALLOW. ANNEKE HUMILIATION
OF SAVINGS TO A SYSTEM ONCE
THEY TRANSITION BACK INTO
PUBLIC MOST IMPORTANTLY
INCARCERATE CREASE WAGES WILL
HELP REDUCE RECIDIVISM REALLY
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE STATE AND ALSO
WE MAKE THEM BETTER. PREPARED
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR OR SENATOR TO
RUSSELL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I RISE TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THE RESOLUTION AND THANK THE
AUTHOR. EVERYONE DESERVES
DIGNITY AND WORK IN CALIFORNIA
WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF OUR LONG
STRUGGLE FOR FAIR AND JUST
WAGES. BUT DIGNITY IN WAR DOES
NOT END WERE PRISON WALLS
BEGIN. IN CALIFORNIA THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO EARN WAGES ARE
EARNING WAGES FAR BELOW THE
NATIONAL NATIONAL AVERAGE. NOR
DOES THIS INDIGNITY AND END
WERE PRISON WALLS AND THERE ARE
FAMILIES OUR COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE STRUGGLING FOR ECONOMIC
SURVIVAL AFTER LOSING THE
SUPPORT OF AN INCARCERATED
FAMILY MEMBER. I APPLAUD THIS
RESOLUTION BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THESE FAMILIES DESERVE THE
SUPPORT THAT HIGHER WAGES WILL
PROVIDE PROVIDE. OUR CONSUMER
ECONOMY BENEFITS FROM THE LABOR
OF THOSE INSIDE PRISON WALLS IT
IS TIME OUR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS OF THIS WORK THANK YOU.
THANKS THANK YOU ROGER ANY FOR
BASE OR DISK ON THIS. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ONE THING
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
FOR. PART OF THIS MEASURE AND
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
WE FIND OURSELVES HERE TODAY
BECAUSE OF. PROPOSITION THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT THIS IS A
DIRECT RESULT OF THE ENDING OF
SLAVERY AND THE PRISON
INDUSTRIAL. COMPLEX I HATE TO
ALL THIS TIME BRACE. IT'S AT
THE CORE OF EVERY. PRACTICE WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY SO- TO
SHOW THAT WE HAVE EVOLVED IN
THAT WE NO LONGER BELIEVE IN
SLAVE LABOR AND SLAVE WAGES
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
AND I RESPECT LAYOUT FOR YOUR
I. OTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ACTIONS I BAIT.
BELL I FOR JUST THEY'RE GOING
TO BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I HAVE A
I JANE. DALLY DOT HI RUSSEL
FIVE OUT JOHNNY BY LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WAY SO HI
TADO. JACKSON I JONES I LABOR I
WIRE HI MITCHELL I MONEY FIVE
MORE LOCK AROUND. NIELSEN PENN
HI I FORTUNE TINO. HI ROB I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBER I LIKE HOW SKI. I WINNER
I WILL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALLED UP TO MEMBERS. FACE FOR
JUST I JANE. DALLY GROWTH TADO.
MORE LOCK. MORALE NIELSEN WELL.
AUGUST THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FALL ITEM ELEVEN CENTER
PANNED. ARE YOU PREPARED. SR
SIXTY NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTE
RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO FRED
KOREMATSU DAY OF CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND THE CONSTITUTION
YOUR PEN FOR JURORS THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT SENATORS AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IT
IS MY HONOR TO PRESENT SR SIXTY
NINE IN RECOGNITION OF FRED
KOREMATSU DATE OF CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND THE CONSTITUTION.
FRED KOREMATSU IS AN AMERICAN
ICON HIS PERSISTENCE IN THE
PURSUIT OF JUSTICE HAS INSPIRED
GENERATIONS. FRED KOREMATSU WAS
ARRESTED IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO WHEN HE
VIOLATED EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY
SIXTY SIX. THE REMOVAL ORDER
FOR AMERICANS OF JAPANESE
ANCESTRY DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
AND A. C. L. A. U. ATTORNEY
DEFENDED HIS CASE PLEASE
CONVICTED IT'S A SUBSEQUENTLY
INCARCERATED AT THE TOPAZ
CONCENTRATION CAMP AND UTAH.
THIS CASE WAS REPEALED WAS
APPEALED AND HURT BY THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR BUT THE
CONVICTION WAS UNFORTUNATELY UP
HELD. HOWEVER FORTY YEARS AFTER
HIS ARREST HE RE OPENED HIS
CASE WITH THE PRO BONO LEGAL
TEAM AND FILED A PETITION FOR
WRIT OF AIR. CORPS ON NOTICE
HIS LAWYERS ARGUED THAT THERE
WAS NEW EVIDENCE THAT SHOWED
SUPPRESSION ALTERATION AND
DESTRUCTION BY US GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS OF EVIDENCE
INDICATING THAT JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE NEITHER DISLOYAL
NOT PREDISPOSED TO ESPIONAGE.
THAT NO FAX SUPPORTED THE
DECISION TO INCARCERATE
JAPANESE AMERICANS IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. THIS
PETITION WAS GRANTED AND HIS
CONVICTION WAS OVERTURNED. THIS
DECISION HAS HAD READ. ON OTHER
CASES INFLUENCE THE BACK EDGE
OF THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
RECOGNIZES THAT THE
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS WAS UNJUST. AND
OCCURRED DUE TO RACIAL
PREJUDICE WARTIME HYSTERIA THE
FAILURE OF POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP. IS DIRECTED TO
SPEAK UP WHEN SOMETHING IS NOT
RIGHT RESONATES EVEN MORE
TODAY. WE MUST REMEMBER HIS
LEGACY AND CONTINUE TO FIGHT TO
MAINTAIN AND AFFIRM OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES GUARANTEED UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE EIGHT LET'S CAUCUS AND
JOINING AND I ON AS SIXTY NINE
THREE. FRED CORN. DAY OF CIVIL
AND THE CONSTITUTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEARCH FOR. MISTER
PRESIDENT SPEAK UP WHEN IT'S
NOT RIGHT. SPEAK UP WHEN IT'S
NOT RIGHT. SPEAK UP WHEN THE
POPULATION SAYS GO THE OTHER
DIRECTION AND YOU KNOW IT'S
WRONG THAT IS THE HARDEST THING
FOR ALL OF US TO DO. WE GET
ELECTED AND SOMETIMES THE
STEREO OF THE MOMENT. GREAT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE WRONG I
DON'T REMEMBER WHO THE NAME OF
THE SENATOR IN THIS BODY WAS
BUT THERE WAS ONE SENATOR WHO
SPOKE UP BECAUSE HE KNEW IT WAS
WRONG. ON THIS BODY IN THIS
HOUSE ON A RESOLUTION DEALING
WITH THE JAPANESE INTERNMENT.
IT IS THE HARDEST THING. AND SO
BEYOND THE LARGER MESSAGE OF
FRED KOREMATSU AND WE'VE
SOLDERED HIS DAUGHTER HERE IN
OTHERS OVER THE YEARS. IT IS
THE HARDEST THING FOR ALL OF US
PARTICULARLY AMONG OUR FRIENDS.
AMONG OUR CONSTITUENTS THE
PEOPLE THAT ELECTED US AND I
JUST THINK THAT THIS RESOLUTION
IS SO IMPORTANT. TO IN EVERY
WAY POSSIBLE AS WE FACE TODAY
ALL SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ASKED TO SPEAK UP
WHERE THEY KNOW THINGS ARE
WRONG IT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
VALUE THAT WE CAN ENGAGE IN.
AND I STAND PROUDLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION FOR THAT
PURPOSE. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS A- THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS I THANK SENATOR
PAN UP FOR RECOGNIZING OF FRED
KOREMATSU FOR TODAY. ON AS YOU
SAID ON IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINE ZERO SIX
SIX THE ORDER RESULT IN THE
INTERNMENT OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
JAPANESE AMERICANS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR CITIZENSHIP STATUS.
FAMILIES WERE SEPARATED HE
REFUSED TO GO TO INTERMINGLE HE
WAS ARRESTED AND CONVICTED HE
APPEALED HIS CASE ALL THE WAY
TO THE SUPREME COURT HE SPOKE
OUT AGAINST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT A TIME WHEN
XENOPHOBIA WAS CONSIDERED
PATRIOTISM. FAST FORWARD TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE SUPREME
COURT REPUDIATED THE KOREMATSU
RULING. NOW COLLEAGUES IT IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST XENOPHOBIA AND
HONOR HEROES LIKE FRED
KOREMATSU FAMILY INCARCERATION
IS HAPPENING EVERY SINGLE DAY
IN THIS COUNTRY. MORE PEOPLE
NEED THE COURAGE OF FRED
KOREMATSU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SCENE NINE SOONER PAN
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE THANK YOU
I THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR THEIR VERY
IMPORTANT REMARKS I WOULD ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THERE ARE
THOSE. AMONG US WHO WISH TO
DRIVE GREATER DIVISIONS AND
FEAR. ABOUT EACH OTHER AND WE
SHOULD NOT ALLOW OTHERS TO
DIVIDE US. WE SHOULD NOT FEAR
EACH OTHER WE SHOULD EMBRACE
EACH OTHER I THINK THAT'S WHAT
FRED KOREMATSU SAID THAT THE
LESSONS THAT UNDER THAT
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY WE HAVE
LEARNED. FROM WORLD WAR TWO.
AND WITH THAT ESPECIALLY OSCAR
NIGHT THAT. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ACTIONS I
BASE I FELL HI GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD FIVE CABRERO I CHAIN.
DALLY I DON I AWESOME I GOT
JOHNNY I LASER I CONSULT. I
GROWS. HERTZBERG FIVE HILL I
WAY SO I TADO I JACKSON I JONES
I LLEVA I REQUIRE I MITCHELL.
HI MY- I MORE LONG I MORAL. I
KNEW. I CAN I FOR TINO I ROB
FIVE ROUTE. HI SKINNER I STERN
I NUMBER NINE I LIKE OWSKI I
WINNER. I WILL I. PLEASE HOLD
UPS MEMBERS CHANGE FIVE GROVE.
ARCH THIRTY KNOWS YOUR THE
MEASURE BY. NOT UP IS FALL
TWELVE SR SEVENTY CENTERED PRO
TEM ACTIONS ARE YOU READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY BY SENATOR
ATKINS OF RELATIVE TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH.
TEMPERATURE ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I RISE TO PRESENT SR
SEVENTY THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES JANUARY IS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA TOPS
MANY LISTS THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD SETTING PRECEDENTS
FOR LAWS THAT VALUE PEOPLE
INCLUSION. AND HOME TO SOME OF
THE NATION'S BEST UNIVERSITIES
AND MOST BEAUTIFUL LANDSCAPES
BUT SADLY CALIFORNIA IS AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE LIST IN TERMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. OUR STATE
HAS AMONGST THE HIGHEST
INCIDENCE OF LABOR AND SEX
TRAFFICKING WE HAVE BECOME A
HOT SPOT FOR PREDATORS BECAUSE
OF OUR MAJOR HARBOURS HIGHWAYS
AIRPORTS ECONOMY AND PROXIMITY
TO THE INTERNATIONAL BORDER.
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND
INSTANCES OF TRAFFICKING IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN REPORTED.
TO THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST TWELVE
TO HEAR. BUT IT'S EVEN TOUGHER
ONE TO HAVE TO EXPERIENCE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN TACKLING
THE ISSUE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
FOR YEARS PASSING LAWS TO
PROTECT AND SUPPORT SURVIVORS.
CRACKDOWN ON PREDATORS AND HELP
IN THIS FORM OF SLAVERY. WE'VE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM SURVIVOR'S
ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE INTO WORD
AND THAT IS PLAYED A POWERFUL
PARTING GUIDING OUR EFFORTS. WE
MUST AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON WAYS TO STOP SEX AND
LABOR TRAFFICKERS FROM
EXPLOITING PEOPLE AND PUT AN
END TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE TO
RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SO WE CAN HELP
THOSE IMPACTED COME OUT OF THE
SHADOWS. FOR THESE REASONS AND
IN SUPPORT OF VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS WHO NEED OUR HELP I
URGE YOU TO VOTE I'D ON SR
SEVENTY. HI SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU PRESIDENT A MEMBERS
OUT TODAY I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION I'M
A PROUD CO AUTHOR WITH THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE ALONG WITH
MANY OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES I
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS TO
EXPERIENCE THIS TERRIBLE CRIMES
SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND THESE
CRIMES GO STRAIGHT TO THE HEART
IT REALLY ATTACKS ARE HUMAN
DIGNITY AND IT SADDENS ME THAT
MANY ARE TROLL IN. AND THAT IS
SHOCKING TO ME AND- PARENTS
PORT AND I ASKED. HOUSE TO DO
US THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
JOE. THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTY AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORT
RESOLUTION FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PLAGUES. CALIFORNIA
AND ESPECIALLY AFFECTS MY
REGION IN SAN DIEGO. IN FACT
THE FBI HAS LISTED SAN DIEGO IS
ONE OF THE THIRTEEN WORST
REGIONS. FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IN OTHER PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
ARE EQUALLY RATED. THIS IS A
DISGRACE TO OUR STATE AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE RESOLUTION AND
MANY PEOPLE THINK THIS IS A FAR
OFF PROBLEM. REALLY ISN'T IT'S
NOT IT'S RIGHT HERE AT HOME
IT'S IN SACRAMENTO IT'S IN LA
IT'S IN SAN DIEGO. IT'S IN THE
BAY AREA. WE HAVE TO GET
SERIOUS COMBAT THE SEVEN. THAT
AFFECTS SOME OF OUR STATES MY
OF OUR POPULAR IN. THE JUST
GLASS NIGHT I. A INTERESTING
KERR. AND I WISH I COULD
REMEMBER TOO BUT IT WAS A
COMMERCIAL ENCOURAGING THE HOME
SERVICES INDUSTRY PLUMBERS
ELECTRICIANS- LANDSCAPERS
PEOPLE WORK IN PEOPLE'S HOMES-
TO KEEP AN EYE OUT. FOR
EVIDENCE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IN THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOODS AND
ACTUALLY GAVE SOME PRETTY GOOD
POINTERS ON HOW TO IDENTIFY IT
AND REACTS TO IT SO AGAIN THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
THE AUTHOR- CENTER RESOLUTION
SEVENTY- IS OF. A VERY GOOD
FIRST STEP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF- THE SUPPORT
RESOLUTION ONE THANK OUR PRO
TEM FOR- BRING THIS FORD. I DO
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT TO IT
LASTED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET-
THIS VERY CHAMBER VOTED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR. DATA
COLLECTION AND RESEACH SO WE
CAN BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN COMBAT
IN A SEX. SEX TRAFFICKING SO
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU- THE
PRO TEM FOR LEADERSHIP BUT
ALSO- APPRECIATE THAT THIS
CHAMBER HAS ALSO BEEN TAKING
ACTION TO TRY TO COMBAT AND
REDUCE- THIS HORRIBLE WITH.
FLEXION IN OUR SOCIETY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
ALSO AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
RESOLUTION AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BRING AWARENESS TO
THE IMPACT THE HARMFUL IMPACT
THAT THE CURRENT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION POLICIES ARE AND
HOW THEY AFFECT- THESE THESE
VICTIMS THESE POLICIES RIGHT
NOW CREATE BARRIERS. TAKE THE
WHO STRUCK A COME FORWARD TO
REPORT THE EVIL THAT THEY IN.
TO BE ABLE TO WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ACCESS THE
PROTECTION SUPPORT THEY NEED.
THIS MEANS THESE SURVIVORS ARE
PUSHED BACK INTO THE SHADOWS RE
TRAFFIC AND NEW VICTIMS ARE
CREATED BY PERPETRATORS WERE
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE. WE MUST
SUPPORT THESE BRAVE SURVIVORS
TO COME FORWARD AND PROTECT
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUE THANK
APPROACH HIM ON THE WOMEN'S
<c.green>AUCUS FOR ALWAYS CHAMPION THIS</c>
ISSUE I SERVE ON THE STATE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS- AS AN
APPOINTEE OF THE PRO TEM BUT-
THIS IS MY THIRD GO ROUND THE
COMMISSION I THINK WHEN I FIRST
SERVED ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO.
I PARTICIPATED IN THE HEARING
AT UCLA A FORMER STATE SENATOR
SHEILA KILL WAS ON THE
COMMISSION AT THAT TIME AND
THAT'S WHEN I LEARNED WE HEARD-
AMAZING STATISTICS ABOUT. THE
INCIDENCE OF CHAT SEX
TRAFFICKING PARTICULARLY AROUND
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETIC EVENTS.
AND MAJOR ATHLETIC EVENTS LIKE
THE SUPER BOWL. AND SO THIS
WEEKEND IN MIAMI I AM SURE THE
INCIDENCE OF SEX TRAFFICKING
WILL INCREASE TENFOLD. THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE YOU KNOW DEMAND
DICTATE SUPPLY AND SO I'M
HOPING AS WE ALL ARE ENJOYING-
THE GAME THIS SUNDAY AND
LOOKING AT ALL THE COMMERCIALS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE- ELECTED TO
WORK A REFUND. AS. HI BROWN
FEWER WOMEN AND BOYS ARE VICTOR
OF FOR AS A RESULT OF MAJOR
ATHLETIC EVENTS- I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SR SEVENTY. THANK
YOU SENATOR SCANNER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE
RESOLUTION AND I WANT TO THANK
OUR PRO TEM NOT ONLY FOR
INTRODUCTION BUT ALSO FOR HER
REFERENCE TO THAT ARE THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THAT WE ARE SEEING
AN IS BOTH. IT'S LABOR AND SEX
THERE'S ED I THINK FOR MANY IT
WAS VIEWED PRIMARILY THROUGH
THE LENS OF THIS IS SEX
TRAFFICKING BUT I THINK THAT
WHAT WE SEE IS THAT IN MANY
CASES IT'S BOTH THE VICTIMS ARE
BEING USED FOR BOTH AND IN
OTHER CASES IT'S JUST ONE OR
THE OTHER AND THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO RATE IS THAT IT'S
MORE CONGESTED NATIONAL SOON
OTHERWISE IT'S MORE THAN JUST
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT
IN FROM OTHER COUNTRIES BUT
DOMESTIC SO. CAN ALL RELATE A
COUPLE OF THINGS IN MY OWN
DISTRICT- OVER A DECADE AGO
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT WHERE A
BERKELEY HIGH STUDENTS NOTICED
THERE'S A MOTEL RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM BERKELEY HIGH
SCHOOL AND THE STUDENTS TO
WRITE FOR THE BERKELEY HIGH
PAPER NOTICED THAT THERE WERE
THESE GIRLS THAT EVERY DAY
WORKS WEEPING IN FRONT OF THIS
MOTEL AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL AND THEY NOTICED EVERY
DAY SEEING THOSE GIRLS KNOWING
THAT THEY WERE SCHOOL AGE AND
WONDERING WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
SO A STAY DURING MY BEST GAVE
REPORTING AND BEGAN TO INTERACT
WITH THESE YOUNG WOMEN AND THEY
FOUND THESE YOUNG WOMEN WERE
BROUGHT OVER BY THE OWNER OF-THE MOTEL WHO ALSO LOTS OF
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEY WERE
SICKLY THE GENERAL NO SIR THIS
FOR THIS PROPERTY BUT PAID.
THEY WERE ALL SO BEING. AT OLD
FOR SEX. EIGHT NINE AS A RESULT
OF THE BERKELEY HIGH ARTICLE
THE WAS A- AND A RING WAS BASIC
STOCK. MEANWHILE IN MY DID WE
HAD SITUATIONS WERE OUTSIDE OF
GROUP HOMES AND OUTSIDE OF
LOCATIONS WHERE GOOD SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED TO OUR FOSTER
YOUTH WE HAD PREDATORS
BASICALLY- RIGHT AROUND OUTSIDE
OF THOSE AREAS. TO RECRUIT
THESE FOSTER THE MOSTLY YOUNG
WOMEN BUT BOYS ALSO INTO THEIR
SEX TRADE AND OF COURSE THESE
FOSTER KIDS ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
VULNERABLE WITH THE LITLE A
WITH FEW ADULTS THAT THEY CAN
RELY ON- DEPEND ON AND OF
COURSE THE PEOPLE THAT DO THIS
ARE VERY GOOD AT GETTING
VULNERABLE PEOPLE TO FEEL THAT
SOMEHOW THEY CAN TRUST THEM AND
RELY ON THEM. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS INTERNATIONAL AND
DOMESTIC FOR LABOR PURPOSES AND
SEX TRAFFICKING PURPOSES THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON.
YES I WANT TO THANK ARE GOOD
LEADER FROM SAN DIEGO- BUT I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT TO THE OTHER
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO THIS
ISN'T JUST CALIFORNIA'S
PROBLEM. THIS IS AN
INTERNATIONAL PROBLEM AND IT'S
ALL ABOUT DE HUMANIZING
PRIMARILY GIRLS AND WOMEN. IT
IS ALSO ABOUT DE HUMANIZING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WHICH IS THE REASON GOVERNMENT
IS SUPPOSED TO EXIST ANYWAY TO
PROTECT THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
AND WHILE IN CALIFORNIA I KNOW
WE HAVE TAKEN STEPS IF YOU'RE
AT THE AIRPORT THERE AND DISHES
THAT SAY IF YOU SUSPECT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HERE'S A NUMBER TO
CALL. WE REQUIRED AT HOTELS I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT MOST OTHER
STATES PROBABLY DON'T EVEN DO
THIS. BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS GANGS RESPONSIBLE FOR
DRUG TRAFFICKING HAVE FOUND IT
SAFER AND MORE PROFITABLE TO
NOW ENGAGE IN SEX TRAFFICKING.
THERE IN LIES THE RUB AND I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON ALL
OF US TO RECOGNIZE THIS PROBLEM
TO RECOGNIZE WHEN WE DEHUMANIZE
HUMAN BEINGS WE THEN CANNONS
THEM WHETHER IT'S IN SEX
TRAFFICKING WHETHER IT'S IN THE
USE OF FREE LABOR. WE ALL HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY AS A HUMAN
COMMUNITY TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO NOT TO
HUMAN RIGHTS AND HUMAN BEING.
AND ONLY AT THE SUPER BOWL ARE
WE GOING TO SEE IN INCREASE IN
THIS KIND OF TRAFFIC. IT IS
ALSO WHAT THEY WEAR THAN FOR
ALL VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS AT ITS PEAK. THIS
IS A PROBLEM FOR THE WAR. IN
OUR SYSTEM. POLL AND SO ARE YOU
APPRECIATE THE GOOD FROM SANDY
BRINGING THIS PUTS FOLK ON WHAT
THE IS CHANGE THIS CULTURE AND
DO MORE TO PROTECT THOSE WHO
ARE VULNERABLE AND DO MORE TO
PROTECT YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN
WHO ARE PRIMARILY THE VICTIMS
OF THE SEX TRAFFICKING WITH
THAT I WOULD GINGIVAL. THANK
YOU SEEN NO FURTHER MIKE'S UP
AND- NO FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS ISSUE MADAM PROTIUM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT ASK FOR AN I.
VOTE. I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IN. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
BY ACTIONS I BASE FIVE BELL. HI
FOUR JUST- I'M SORRY BRADFORD
HI I HAVE A- HI CHANG I DALLY I
DON I DURAZO I TELL JOHNNY I
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATES. HI
GROWTH HERTZBERG. HELLO HI WAY
SO I- TADO FIVE JACKSON. I
JONES. LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL I MONEY. I MORE LOCK
FIVE MORE ROUNDS I NIELSEN HI
PAM HI PERSON TINA. I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN. BY
AMBER HI WHAT HOUSEKEEPING I
WINNER I WILL. I MADAM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
REGIS I GROVE HERTZBERG HI
JONES HI. ALL RIGHTS THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR JONES FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. MISTER PRESIDENT THE
REPUBLICANS LIKE TO CAUCUS FOR
A BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME PLEASE
OKAY REPUBLICAN CAUCUS NOBODY
LOUNGE. A CAPSULE **** ARMS.
YES YOU WERE ASKING YOUR VILE
SIXTY ON THE FLOORS JUST
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE ****
ON.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS WERE
PREPARED TO CONTINUE WHAT'S IN
IT THIRD READING ALL. WE'RE
READY TO TAKE UP FALL ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. CENTER WHEN ARE
YOU PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. SENATE BILL FIFTY
BY SENATOR WEINER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING WHEN YOU'RE
WHEN YOU'RE PREPARED. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
OUR COLLEAGUE THIS BILL IS ON
RECONSIDERATION- WEHAD A
ROBUST- DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
YESTERDAY AND I APPRECIATE
THAT- SP FIFTY IS ABOUT. THE
SENATE AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT TAKING
MEANINGFUL ACTION TO ADDRESS
OUR DEBILITATING HOUSING CRISIS
ARE THREE AND A HALF MILLION
HOMES SHORTAGE. THE FACT THAT
WE RANK ALMOST DEAD LAST IN
HOMES PER CAPITA AMONG THE
FIFTY STATES. THE FACT THAT
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN PART DUE
TO RESTRICTIVE. ZONING HAS
COLLAPSED OVER THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS- AND WE ARE IN A WORLD OF
HURT IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE SEE IT EVERY DAY- THE
SPRING. AND THE- PEOPLE LIVING
IN THEIR CARS YOUNG PEOPLE NOT
BEING ABLE TO ENVISION A FUTURE
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
COMMUNITY. CHILDREN MOVING
AWAY. AND NOT BE ABLE TO MOVE
BACK HOME TO THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY GREW UP. YOUNG
FAMILIES. POINT OF ORDER
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRERS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE ODD DEBATE OR PRESENTATION
AT A RECONSIDERATION. THEY TOLD
ME. OKAY OB ONCE FOR A
RECONSIDERATION IS BRAD GRANTED
IT TAKES US BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL BILL SO WE CAN-
PROCEED WITH THANK YOU A
DISCUSSION CENTER WINNER YOU
MAY CONTINUE. YOUNG FAMILIES TO
MAKE A LIVES HERE WHO ARE
FORCED TO MOVE OUT OF THEIR
CITY OUT OF THE REGION. OUT OF
THE STATE ENTIRELY BECAUSE
THERE IS NO HOUSING FUTURE FOR
THEM IN CALIFORNIA. BUSINESSES
THAT CHOOSE TO EXPAND OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THERE
WERE WORKERS CANNOT OBTAIN
HOUSING ANYWHERE NEAR THEIR
JOBS SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
SHUTTING DOWN BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT MAINTAIN. A STABLE WORK
FORCE DUE TO THE COST OF
HOUSING- AND THIS DID NOT JUST
HAPPENED IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
LIVER POLICY CHOICES AND ONE OF
THOSE POLICY CHOICES. IS THE
ADOPTION HELLO FOR INDIA.
ACTIVE IS OPEN WHERE YOU CAN
BUILD A MULTI UNIT BUILDING. IN
AN ENTIRE CITY OR A LARGE
PORTION OF THE CITY WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY. TO TAKE A
STEP FORWARD TO REFORM OUR
BROKEN ZONING SYSTEM ARE BROKEN
HOUSING STATUS QUO AND IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OTHER HOUSING
POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. AND
KNOW WILL MOVE FORWARD THIS
YEAR I THINK THAT WE CAN CREATE
A VERY STRONG FOUNDATION FOR A
BRIGHTER HOUSING FUTURE- AFTER
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY OUT TONIGHT. OKAY
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SCENE HEARING ON. FROM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA ATKINS. EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT NO WELL. HI GORGEOUS
NO BRADFORD. KIND OF A YELLOW I
CHANGE. DALLY I DON NO THERE
ARE SO NO DOUBT JOHNNY I LASER
NO CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG NO HELLO NO WAY SO I-
TADO FIVE JACKSON NO JONES NO
LLEVA I REQUIRE FIVE MITCHELL
NO MONEY I WARLOCK. MORALE.
WE'LL SEND I CAN I FORTUNE TINA
NO NO ROTH. HI RUBIO. NO
SKINNER I STERN NO AMBER. WHITE
HOUSE SKI. WINNER I WILL NO I'M
SICK TO PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. ALAN NO ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD CHANG. GROWTH. MORE
LOCK FIVE MORALE. NUMBER WHITE
HOUSE SKI. SIR WINNER MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE JUST GONNA TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE MEMBERS WILL YOU
PLEASE STAY ON THE FLOOR REMAIN
ON THE FLOOR.
SENATOR DODD FOR
WHAT PURPOSE. YEAH THE
PRESIDENT- A POINT OF ORDER I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT WE'RE DOING.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE. APOLLO
MENTERI INQUIRE. I WE'RE WE'RE
FOURTEEN ARE KOLLEGAL LOW
COMMON COURTESY TO HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO WORK THIS ISSUE AND
DISCUSS SMITH- DISCUSS IT WITH
OUR MEMBERS SO WE'RE JUST A
FORTY ON THAT SAME COMMON
COURTESY THAT WE WOULD TRY TO
EXTEND ANY OF OUR MEMBERS AS IT
RELATES TO THEIR HOUSE FOLLOW
ITEM THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE WILL RECONVENE IN
THIRTY SECONDS. WE WILL
RECONVENE IN THIRTY SECONDS.
MEMBERS WERE LOOKING TO CALL ON
FILE FILE ITEM EIGHT. S. B.
FIFTY. MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ARCHULETA. BRADFORD
CHANG. GROWTH MORALE. NUMBER
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I'M SECTOR
CALLED APPS MEMBERS WARMER TIME.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD. CHANG
GROWTH. MORALE AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI. YEAH. YEAH.
I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA BRADFORD.
CHANG GROWTH. MORALE AMBERG
WHITE HOUSE SKI. ONE MORE TIME
MA'AM SECTOR. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD. CHANG GROWTH. MORALE
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI. ALL
EYES EIGHTEEN KNOWS FIFTEEN
MEASURE FAILS. CENTER ACHEN
SUGGESTS IS KILLER. MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. THEY
COLLEAGUES LET ME- LET ME START
BY EXPRESS AND- MY MOST SINCERE.
APPRECIATION TO THE REPUBLICANS
AND TO THE DEMOCRATS TO THE
SENATORS IN THIS CHAMBER FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE PATIENCE. YOUR
RESPECT OF PROCESS. YOUR
RESPECT OF YOUR COLLEAGUES. AND
WITH THE INDULGENCE OF THE BODY
AS WE CLOSE. IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE COUPLE OF DAYS- I
DON'T REMEMBER ANOTHER TIME
LIKE THIS BUT I AM GOING TO-
MAKE COMMENTS BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS.
I WANT TO MAKE IT AS CLEAR AS I
CAN- THAT EVEN THOUGH A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT HAS BEEN
THE HIGHEST PROFILE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I CAN REMEMBER IN A
LONG TIME ONE THAT- HAS SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. FROM BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS-
DIDN'T GET ENOUGH SUPPORT TODAY
AS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION BUT I
FEEL COMPELLED TO SAY AND I
THINK YOU ALL KNOW THIS THIS IS
NOT THE END OF THE STORY. I
WANT TO PERSONALLY COMMITTED TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU. TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
I HOUSING PRODUCTION BILL TO
HELP ALLEVIATE OUR HOUSING
CRISIS WILL HAPPEN THIS YEAR.
TO THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE SUPPORTERS OF
SB FIFTY. YOU HAVE BEEN
PASSIONATE YOU HAVE BEEN
PERSISTENT IN ADVOCATING FOR
THIS BILL AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I HAVE BEEN WHERE YOU ARE
IT TOOK ME TWO YEARS TO PASS A
SPEECH TO. THE ONGOING FUNDING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
OTHERS HAD TRIED FOR YEARS TO
DO IT BEFORE ME. THE GOOD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO. HAS
BEEN WHERE YOU ARE TODAY. BUT
AFTER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
DISCUSSIONS NOT ALL OF THEM
EASY. AND GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS. USE FORCE BILL
DID BECOME LAW.TO THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT S. B.
FIFTY. YOU HAVE AFFECTED LEE
SHARED HOW IT WILL IMPACT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. BUT NOW IT IS TIME. FOR
ALL SIDES TO STEP UP. SB FIFTY
MIGHT NOT BE COMING FORWARD.
RIGHT NOW. BUT THE STATUS QUO
CANNOT STAND. ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES SAID THAT IN THEIR
REMARKS THIS WEEK AND I DON'T
REMEMBER WHERE THEY WERE
WHETHER THEY WERE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SO I
THINK THERE IS FULL AGREEMENT.
THAT THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
ALL I DO NOT KNOW YET EXACTLY
WHAT THE NEXT STEPS LOOK LIKE I
DO KNOW THIS. EVERYONE NEEDS TO
GET READY TO COME TO THE TABLE.
EVERYONE NEEDS TO GET READY FOR
SOME COMPROMISE. I HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILL WILL SUCCEED
THIS YEAR. SO I'M GONNA ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME. TO JOIN THE
GOVERNOR. TO JOIN THOSE OF US
ALL OF US WHO KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE TO COME TOGETHER BRING
YOUR IDEAS BRING SOLUTIONS.
BRING IDEAS AND SOLUTIONS
COMMUNICATE COLLABORATE AND
COMPROMISE THE SHAPE THE BILL
THAT CALIFORNIANS MUST HAVE TO
HELP ALLEVIATE OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING ME. FOR THOSE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WE- WE'LL
AGAIN COME TOGETHER. FOUR FOUR
SESSION ON MONDA FEBRUARY
THIRD AT TWO PM. THANK YOU THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY
AT TWO PM. SENATE STANDS IN
RECESS.